York Strand had his pass stolen
by Cole Smith right up the scene
charging after assistance he's got it he
scor and sistence wins the battle here gets that
net front stays on his feet and then lifts the
puck back shat across to ma Oly ma longrange
wrist shot knocked down by hman and he's got
Hegel Brandon Hegel in alone shoots scores
slipping through the defense watch Victor
come out towards the shooter does a terrific job
then look how quickly he threads the needle that
is the perfect pass that window was as he fires
a shot that Blackwood got a piece of here's a
breakaway for zland in alone guard his first goal
as a shark baby in Zin for part of the season in
Washington picked up out of the box comes Smith
and he's got it on a breakaway Ryan orelli behind
him Smith scores two goals in the first period
time to line up his shot just an intelligent
player you're going to see O'Reilly sneak in right
behind that allows Smith to wind up and what does
he want to do too how long is the rebuild going
to take ainson in alone [Applause] score Atkinson
is having a game came alive especially in this
second period but good job by the Flyers to break
the puck out they've got great support coming off
the board getting it out to take him and his shot
away turns it over Far Side in Colorado looking
to break there's the opportunity shorthanded score
in cian were the ab's most aggressive penalty
killing group good play on the boards by Josh
down low the puck hops off the Stick of shin
it finds Walkin 8 seconds in the period he's
out of the box he's alone he's on goal he scores
Waits Waits a very experienced goal scorer he's
waiting for Jordan Bennington to just move give
him a little bit of something and he goes right
above the pad under the arm he's got it car in
Pursuit on the near side that puck is loose B
ahead Logan o con turns on the jet can he do it
again he scores that's his second goal in his
many games you have just one defenseman it's
D'Angelo he gets caught flat-footed obviously
the goal but everything else deide good shots
oh here we go B R's got a man open Evangelista
with a new stick coming in Evangelista oh just
want to get the puck deep but it's a soft play
deep doesn't get there quick transition pass
and this is how you want to see it as Kaden
Primo mat cutting it to the four score what a
goal Mike Mat Mike Mat is looking to drop this
puck back and everybody overplays the drop and he
turns around and says well if you're going to do
that I'm going the other way it was traded over
to to the Hawks in the off season aggravated a
shoulder injury on Saturday night here's Patra
and a load he scores the space in the middle
of the Isis this is really strong work by ptra to
stay with Cory Perry looking for run cyinder takes
the shot that hit PR off tried to give it back
but B greu intercepts great pass patrono with a
game on his stick scores Anaheim with their first
road win of the season he waited for proov to get
in front but a perfect pass with proov up there
in the play offensively to the slot great back
check Deon Shaw away from Brendan Lemieux on a
line change and camped out sh's in he scores Deon
Shore but as hard as he threw it you got to think
he's trying to good stick by Hartman he's Off to
the Races Hartman on the Breakaway he scor trick
it's a good defensive play he hustles to get out
there nice stick breaks it up and it's Off to
the Races he loads this stick up making keer
think he's going to shoot it tor Cruz gave it
away to Pon pass Miller's alone shorthanded TT
Miller stores pson is's able to come up with
the puck right there it's right on his tape
will saucer pass Miller holds for long enough
[Music] get unable to move it further than the
Seattle blue look out here comes mccan breaking
in he has a chance oh a beautiful backhand goal
over to his forehand and then he goes backhand
right into the wide open net and avoids the net
just a beautiful play and a nice job by Alexi
cus to win a battle bring it ahead short hand
of mcel he scores holy jumping what a nice play
by m Michael forehand backhand up over top of
the Fallen goal tender who ended up doing a
snow angel the offside D is taking that man
driving through here's a chance for Skinner now
catching up to the puck on a breakway Skinner dig
scor but good pressure here and kiers out not able
to get able to get that and J skner picks it up in
motion now he's got a breakway for the hatrick
look DAV it inin and he scores the hatrick for
B davic two hat tricks tonight short-handed goal
for the blues and the third goal of the night for
pav B naav he's gassed here he's digging in deep
just to get ahead of the players said in the off
seon at Camp actually and he was disappointed
his word now the blues get it cyu he's in the
clear Kyu back Ender he scores in motion he's
almost Unstoppable you're not going to be able
to catch him and that's a really difficult
suder duaine Springs it Sean has a step Sean
[Applause] scores Tyler Sean K game he
taking 26 here's a lead pass qu Hughes
to the game [Applause] J 43 overtime winner
back battle down and back Evans eel anolin
it ships it to Center try to break in he's got
space yesie anolin to the for half score what
a [Applause] goal I'm not sure Aiden Hill would
have too detailed a book on Jessie Ulin but it's a
good play by Ulin Anin to pop it out in that zone
now they work it out to the Blue Line broken up
in a break short-handed break can in decks scor
sweet hands from Adrien Kee a short handed goal
and the kings were extra aggressive here can't
they anticipated but watch this man and the blues
get it back in a feet ahead and Hayes he's got
a breakaway in the CLA Hayes scores Kevin Hayes
coyotes continue to press but good middle defense
by sod and then Kevin Hayes takes off up the ice
and then what a move here everybody thought he
was going to the back as that's tipped by vavic
and neighbors gets the loose Puck he's in the
clar shoots he scores holy jumping what a goal
by Jake neighbors under control under duress look
at this forehand backhand smooth as silk puts that
one in the back of the net R put it between his
own skate STS and separates him with the buck
headman pass for barzel on a breakway score it's
a little deception right there we don't always
see it look at the moves and then keeping the
golender guessing is he going to go forehand is
he going to go backend comp to gain five Stevenson
missed took a couple penalties this will lead to
a breakaway Conor McDavid in on Thompson backer
store all the way over to the backhand and Tucks
it around the left P of Thompson good stick
by Faber knocks it away from bavage Long Shot
blocked up front by broin he's able to spring
Baldi Matt Baldi in he [Music] [Applause] scores
the two-on-one possibility for the
Sharks and a pass for duclair he's
scor the but granin finds that little area to put
it into that lead pass for duclair and barries on
a beautiful little move to the forehead back
for Jacob trouba high and save by Blackwood as
burrow sends it to duclair on a breakaway scores
Anthony duclair comes back to New York and puts
the Sharks up one to nothing Kemp shot deflected
by doson chipped on by hrom Paso a chance to win
it [Applause] scores no history tonight on Long
Island JG Pou completes the comeback one timer got
to spare in The Twig snaps in half and that allows
scandel a breakway shorthanded mov the [Music]
back and the scandy man can unreal play with that
long reach that you talked about he's used it
to disrupt plays and make good defensive plays
this time it's an absolute Mona Lisa beautiful
goal
what